>> Will Sentance: Nhưng đây là câu hỏi.
Tôi không chỉ lấy dữ liệu đó từ Twitter để không sử dụng nó.
Tôi có nó để sử dụng nó, trưng bày nó, bất kể nó có thể là gì.
Nhưng tôi không biết khi nào dữ liệu đó sẽ quay trở lại.
Nó có thể quay lại bất cứ lúc nào.
Vì vậy, tôi sẽ cần JavaScript để bằng cách nào đó khi dữ liệu quay trở lại và
được lưu trữ trong một thuộc tính, tự động chạy một số mã trên đó để sử dụng.
Nhưng tôi sẽ làm điều đó như thế nào?
Mọi người cho rằng mảng trống này
trong tài sản hoàn thành của riêng mình cũng là một điều cực kỳ quan trọng.
Mảng trống này sẽ có, hoặc chúng ta có thể đặt vào đó bất kỳ hàm nào, bất kỳ mã nào,
mà chúng tôi muốn tự động có với sự trợ giúp của JavaScript
được kích hoạt để chạy khi thuộc tính giá trị được điền vào.
Điều này xảy ra khi dữ liệu quay trở lại từ Twitter,
điều này xảy ra bất cứ khi nào nó xảy ra.
Và nó sẽ tự động kích hoạt, tại thời điểm đó, dữ liệu
trở lại từ Twitter, được cập nhật về thuộc tính giá trị, tự động.
Nó sẽ tự động kích hoạt bất kỳ chức năng nào được lưu trữ trong mảng này.
Trong JavaScript, bạn có thể lưu trữ các hàm như trong một danh sách.
Và thông thường, bạn có thể lưu trữ một loạt các hàm ở đây,
chúng ta có thể đặt một hàm.
Và bất kỳ hàm nào chúng tôi gắn bó trong mảng này sẽ được tự động kích hoạt để chạy
khi thuộc tính giá trị được cập nhật.
Và chờ đợi nó,
dữ liệu đó trong thuộc tính giá trị sẽ được tự động chèn làm đầu vào,
làm đối số để điền vào tham số của bất kỳ hàm nào được lưu trữ tại đây.
Vì vậy, hãy xem chức năng hiển thị đó ở đó, có một chút tham số dữ liệu của họ.
Nếu chúng ta chỉ có thể lưu trữ màn hình trong mảng đó,
nó sẽ tự động chạy và dữ liệu của chúng tôi quay lại sẽ điền vào,
thông số dữ liệu đó khi nó tự động chạy khi hiển thị dưới dạng tự động chạy.
Nhưng làm thế nào chúng ta sẽ hiển thị vào mảng đó?
Làm cách nào để tôi thường thực sự có màu đỏ tươi để phù hợp trên bản đồ này?
Tôi thường thêm vào phương thức nào?
Tôi có phải thêm hai mảng không?
>> Loa 2: Đẩy. >> Will Sentance: Đẩy.
Nó nằm trên các thuộc tính chưa hoàn thành.
Bạn chỉ cần nghĩ xem tôi sẽ làm gì thông thường.
Dữ liệu tương lai, dấu chấm.
>> Loa 2: Chấm, chưa đạt, chấm, đẩy.
>> Will Sentance: Chấm, đẩy và sau đó chuyển vào chức năng hiển thị.
Thật không may, chúng tôi không thể làm điều đó nhưng về cơ bản, nó đúng.
Chúng tôi không thể làm điều đó.
Có ai biết tại sao chúng ta không thể làm điều đó từ những gì tôi đã nói trước đó không?
Tom? >> Người nói 2: Đó là một tài sản ẩn.
>> Will Sentance: Tài sản ẩn.
Thuộc tính ẩn, thậm chí không thể truy cập vào điều này.
Chính xác ngay từ Tolls Pom.
Đừng hoảng sợ.
JavaScript cung cấp cho chúng ta một phương pháp được tích hợp sẵn cho phép chúng ta bất cứ điều gì chúng ta vượt qua
cho dù nó như là đầu vào sẽ được lấy và mắc kẹt trong mảng đó.
Nhân tiện, đằng sau hậu trường, họ đang làm gì
dữ liệu để thực hiện đẩy đó?
Và những gì mọi người có thể nhận ra có thể là ẩn, không ẩn.
Bạn có thể phát hiện ra điều gì có thể là phương pháp gắn một hàm vào đó
mảng chưa thực hiện, Peter?
>> Người nói 2: Vậy thì.
>> Will Sentance: Chính xác, phương thức Then, phương thức dấu chấm Then, chính xác, và
đó là những gì chúng ta sẽ thấy.
Nhân tiện, chúng ta cũng sẽ thấy trong giây lát sau,
chúng ta sẽ xem một chút sau, phương pháp đó đến từ đâu?
Bởi vì nó không có ở đây. Nó không có trên đối tượng này?
Chúng ta sẽ thấy, một khi chúng ta ở trong một phiên quá lâu,
chúng ta sẽ xem phương pháp đó thực sự đến từ đâu vào chiều nay.
Đi thôi.
Nhưng bây giờ, hãy làm chính xác dòng đó ở đó.
Hãy lấy một cái gì đó sẽ hoạt động ở đây.
Bởi vì không có ích gì khi mang dữ liệu trở lại từ Twitter chỉ dành cho
nó biến mất trong thuộc tính giá trị.
Và chúng tôi không biết những gì sẽ hiển thị nên chúng tôi không thể sử dụng nó trực tiếp.
Chúng tôi phải đảm bảo rằng chúng tôi có một chức năng được lưu trữ ở đây.
Nó sẽ được tự động chạy bằng JavaScript cho chúng tôi.
Vì vậy, chúng ta bắt đầu,
sau đó chấm dữ liệu trong tương lai
chuyển toàn bộ định nghĩa chức năng hiển thị.
Được rồi, vì vậy dữ liệu trong tương lai là đối tượng này ở đây.
Nó có một tài sản chưa hoàn thành.
Tôi sẽ không đặt tất cả tên tài sản và chúng tôi có tài sản chưa hoàn thành và
Bất cứ điều gì trôi qua đến lúc đó, nó sẽ chỉ được ghi lại, xin lỗi.
Đó có phải là một từ ở Mỹ?
Nó là. >> Người nói 2: Có.
>> Will Sentance: Từ tiếng Anh giống như một từ bông thế kỷ 19 sẽ được sử dụng.
Bất cứ khi nào nó phân tích cú pháp, nó sẽ được lấy và mắc kẹt trong đó.
Và đó chính xác là những gì chúng tôi làm.
Chúng tôi sử dụng chức năng hiển thị và mắc kẹt vào mảng chưa thực hiện.
Hãy đặt nó vào.
Đây rồi, chức năng hiển thị của chúng ta trong mảng chưa thực hiện.
Nhìn kìa, không đẹp sao?
Trời ơi.
[LAUGH] Aha,
đó là tất cả những gì đạt được bởi hai dòng.
Nhưng nữ thần này đã sắp đặt hết rồi sao?
Bạn cá là nó có.
Chúng tôi đã thiết lập tất cả bây giờ.
Chúng tôi đang nói chuyện với Internet trong nền.
Chúng tôi có một kết nối tốt đẹp với một đối tượng đẹp ở đây trong JavaScript.
Nó sẽ được lấp đầy bằng giá trị của chúng tôi khi thời gian đến từ mạng
yêu cầu phản hồi.
Kayla cho biết, mảng đã hoàn thành cũ hiện có một chức năng sẽ
tự động chạy khi dữ liệu đó quay trở lại.
Đã được thực hiện.
Chúng ta phải tiếp tục với tốc độ gần như là một phần nghìn giây.
Dòng nào qua.
Ethan, chúng ta đánh dòng nào ở một phần nghìn giây?
>> Người thuyết trình 2: Nhật ký bảng điều khiển, tôi đầu tiên.
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời, tôi yêu mọi người ở lại như vậy.
Lấy nét cũng chính xác, nhật ký bảng điều khiển ('Tôi là người đầu tiên'),
nó ở trong một bảng điều khiển.
Và chúng tôi có, Tôi đầu tiên.
Nó ở đây ở tốc độ 1 phần nghìn giây.
>> Will Sentance: Một điều tôi hối tiếc về điều này là điều này ở đây là như vậy
gần với tạo hưng ở bên phải.
Vì vậy, hãy di chuyển điều này một chút.
Cảm giác sẵn sàng, đó là một nửa marathon là bao lâu, phải không?
>> Will Sentence: 3 dặm, 3 dặm.
Em gái tôi đang chạy marathon đầy đủ vào tháng Ba, em yêu, gì cũng được.
Rất tự hào về cô ấy, rất tự hào, rất tự hào.
Vậy chúng ta đang sử dụng cái nào ở đây?
Chúng tôi đang sử dụng tính năng yêu cầu mạng, phải không?
Nhãn là gì, mọi người?
>> Diễn giả 3: Tìm nạp. >> Will Sentance: Tìm nạp, chính xác, vâng,
lấy.
>> Will Sentance: Đó là nhãn JavaScript của chúng tôi để sử dụng yêu cầu mạng cho
lẫn nhau.
Nhưng nó có hai hướng, vì vậy
nó cũng có hậu quả trong JavaScript, khá tuyệt vời.
Được rồi, vì vậy khi tôi đang làm điều đó, bạn sẽ không tin những gì đã xảy ra.
Twitter đã gửi lại thành công cho chúng tôi tại, giả sử, chúng tôi nên nói gì,
như 270 mili giây, tương tự như vậy?
Đúng, 270 mili giây.
Với 270 mili giây, chúng tôi nhận được tin tốt.
Chúng tôi đã nhận lại dữ liệu, một thông báo phản hồi từ Twitter
ở 270, hoàn thành và nó đã quay trở lại.
Được rồi, trang trình bày đơn giản ở đây, đã trở lại dưới dạng một chuỗi nhỏ xinh ở đây, Xin chào.
Sau khi hoàn thành, đó là những gì đã trở lại.
Và cô ấy quay trở lại trong một đối tượng vì anh ấy nói rằng hãy gói thành một dạng đối tượng nhưng
chúng ta có thể lấy thuộc tính của dữ liệu đó.
Và nó đây, là chuỗi cao với một tweet tuyệt vời.
Theo dõi người này, hmm?
Vì vậy, sau khi hoàn thành, chúng tôi đã nhận được phản hồi đáng yêu này, nhưng
nó bị kẹt trong trình duyệt web.
Làm sao?
Làm thế nào, Todd, nó quay trở lại JavaScript?
Nó sẽ được gán vào cái gì trong bộ nhớ chung trong JavaScript?
>> Diễn giả 2: Giá trị dữ liệu trong tương lai.
>> Will Sentance: Giá trị dữ liệu tương lai thuộc tính tại chỗ.
Và lúc đó, anh ta sẽ kích hoạt những gì để chạy, Todd?
>> Loa 2: Các chức năng chưa hoàn thành.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, các chức năng chưa được thực hiện, nói tốt.
Mà cụ thể, đây là của chúng tôi?
>> Loa 2: Màn hình. >> Will Sentance: Chức năng hiển thị,
với những gì là đầu vào của nó?
>> Người nói 2: Giá trị.
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời, thuộc tính giá trị là giá trị, chuỗi?
>> Người nói 2: Xin chào. >> Will Sentance: Xin chào.
Tuyệt vời từ Todd, rất tốt.
Vì vậy, chúng ta đang ở đây, muộn hơn ở 270 mili giây.
270 mili giây,
chúng tôi sẽ gọi, và bạn có thể đã đi, giữ máy, thực sự?
Gì?
Chúng tôi sẽ chỉ đặt nó vào ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
Chúng tôi sẽ gọi hiển thị với đầu vào là
xin chào, nó đây.
Một số màu của tôi bắt đầu trở nên.
Hiển thị với đầu vào là hi và hoàn toàn mới.
Mọi người?
>> Diễn giả 3: Bối cảnh thực thi.
>> Will Sentance: Đúng vậy.
Chúng ta đã bắt đầu, chúng ta đã đặt những phần trăm vào cuối?
Không, những thứ này sẽ tự động bị kẹt cho
chúng tôi bằng JavaScript, vẫn là một bối cảnh thực thi hoàn toàn mới.
Vì vậy, và vào nó, chúng tôi đi và sau đó là địa phương.
>> Will Sentance: Bộ nhớ là những gì dữ liệu đi vào, Todd,
chỉ là nhắc nhở chúng tôi một lần nữa.
Giá trị là? >> Loa 2: Cao.
>> Will Sentance: Cao, nhưng hiển thị bên trong, nhãn cho nó là gì?
>> Diễn giả 2: Dữ liệu. >> Will Sentance: Dữ liệu, vâng, ngay tại chỗ.
Đây rồi.
Dữ liệu và sau đó chúng tôi điều khiển dữ liệu nhật ký, nghĩa là chúng tôi điều khiển nhật ký, Todd?
>> Loa 2: Cao. >> Di chúc: Cao,
Todd không mệt mỏi khi nói cao.
Nó đây, và ở 270 mili giây, mọi người.
Chúng tôi có một bản ghi bảng điều khiển.
Xin chào, Chúa ơi.
Trời ơi.
[LAUGH] Chúa ơi, nhìn kìa.
Tất cả chức năng tìm nạp đáng kinh ngạc của thanh sáng kiến ​​đó thật đáng kinh ngạc,
không hoạt động.
Chức năng mặt tiền, đã kích hoạt công việc nền này,
kích hoạt yêu cầu mạng.
Tắt Internet, mang lại dữ liệu.
Nó sẽ đi đâu, và chúng ta sẽ làm gì với nó?
Đừng hoảng sợ.
Chúng tôi có ngay trong JavaScript một đối tượng đẹp,
đối tượng hứa hẹn, với hai thuộc tính.
Một, một giá trị, đã tự động
cập nhật với Chào, điều đó đã trở lại sau khi nói
với Internet ở chế độ nền, phía bên kia của các lần tìm nạp hoạt động.
Và khi nó quay trở lại, chúng ta không biết ai sẽ quay lại, đừng hoảng sợ.
Chúng tôi đã có một chức năng sẵn sàng để tự động chạy, với đầu vào là
giá trị thuộc tính quay trở lại hoặc giá trị của dữ liệu quay lại từ Twitter.
Khi đầu vào của chức năng đó ở màn hình 230 mili giây bị kẹt trên
mặt mát mẻ với đầu vào cao và chúng tôi đã có thể điều khiển log hi.